[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política si os
pregunto por cuáles son las fronteras
más calientes del planeta estoy seguro
de que podríais darme muchas respuestas
diferentes probablemente diría escora
del norte y corea del sur la india y
pakistán irán e irak grecia y turquía
venezuela y colombia azerbaiyán y
armenia al fin y al cabo quien no tiene
vecinos problemáticos en buena medida
gracias a ello veis al político que en
una colección de temas interminables y
en esta ocasión nos vamos a desplazar
hasta una frontera que se comporta casi
igual que un volcán lleva décadas
inactiva dormida sin protagonizar
grandes titulares pero hay amigos en los
últimos tiempos ha despertado y bayas y
ha despertado de qué forma
argelia corta lazos diplomáticos con
marruecos a medida que aumentan las
tensiones tampoco es que las relaciones
entre ambos vecinos dieran para mucho
[Música]
la frontera que comparten marruecos y
argelia está cerrada desde el 94 y ambos
países llevan enfrentados desde mucho
tiempo antes por la ocupación que
marruecos realizó del sáhara occidental
aún así en los últimos tiempos la
tensión ha estado creciendo y el
ministro de exteriores argelino incluso
culpó a marruecos de llevar a cabo
acciones hostiles y si en cierta forma
es habitual que ángel culpe a rabat de
todo lo malo que le pasa desde la
existencia de grupos separatistas en la
región de cabilia hasta la brutal ola de
incendios que el país ha padecido este
verano pero amigos amigas en esta
ocasión hablamos de algo diferente así
que la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
muy clara que ha llevado a argelia a
cortar sus lazos diplomáticos con
marruecos tan mal se ha portado rabat
para que su vecino haya tomado esta
decisión hay peligro real de que las
cosas se vayan de madre y marroquíes y
argelinos terminen a tortazo limpio hoy
en visual político vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
y arenas olvidadas
argel y marruecos nunca se han llevado
bien ambos países se ven como las
grandes potencias del magreb y esa
rivalidad siempre termina generando
fricciones para colmo ambos países
comparten 1600 kilómetros de frontera
una frontera que francia la antigua
potencia colonial nunca tuvo demasiado
interés en trazar con precisión haciendo
que la línea que separa ambos
territorios sea difusa así que una de
las primeras cosas que hicieron ambos
países en cuanto lograron su
independencia fue la de enviar más y más
tropas a la frontera con el objetivo de
ampliar su territorio así comenzó la
llamada guerra de las arenas durante
1963 se produjeron numerosos choques
fronterizos que para lo único que
sirvieron fue para alimentar la
rivalidad y la enemistad entre los dos
vecinos
[Música]
desde entonces el mayor punto de
conflicto ha estado siempre relacionado
con la antigua provincia española del
sáhara occidental en 1975 marruecos le
invadió con la marcha verde y en
cuestión de meses estalló una guerra
entre los invasores y el grupo
independentista del frente polisario y a
pesar de contar con el apoyo material de
argelia lo cierto es que los combates no
fueron nada pero que nada bien para los
intereses saharauis las tropas de hassan
segundo no dudaron ni un segundo en usar
napalm y fósforo blanco lo que provocó
la huida saharaui a los campos de
refugiados ubicados en argelia
180 mil saharauis malviven desde
entonces en el área de tindúf una vasta
llanura desértica en pleno desierto del
sahara
la guerra entre marruecos y el polisario
prosiguió hasta que en
1989 se alcanzó una tregua gracias a la
mediación de la onu y el acuerdo entre
ambas partes para celebrar un referéndum
si ese referéndum que nunca se celebró y
seguramente nunca lo hará la cuestión es
que esa tregua de 1989 fue vista como
una oportunidad para el magreb y
precisamente este fue el momento en el
que se creó la umma la unión del magreb
árabe una realización creada para
estimular el libre comercio entre
argelia libia mauritania marruecos y
túnez y sabéis que el éxito fue
inmediato las fronteras se abrieron y se
eliminaron los controles de visados el
comercio se movía libremente de un país
a otro pero amigos la armonía la armonía
apenas duró cinco años la guerra civil
sumió argelia en el caos y todas las
esperanzas depositadas en la umma se
desvanecieron de repente
en 1994 hombres armados entran metidos
en el hotel atlas asñi de marrakech
acabando con la vida de dos turistas
españoles casan segundo acusó a argelia
de estar detrás del atentado y como
respuesta marruecos expulsó
repentinamente a miles de residentes y
turistas argelinos al tiempo que volvió
a exigir visados entonces los generales
de argelia respondieron fortificando y
cerrando sus fronteras
[Música]
han pasado casi 30 años y durante todo
este tiempo la frontera ha estado
cerrada durante años el petróleo y el
gas ocuparon la economía argelina el
país tenían los recursos para financiar
su desarrollo pero cuando los precios de
los combustibles fósiles se desplomaron
angelia volvió a sumirse en el caos
especialmente desde que en 2019 las
protestas populares pusieron fin a los
20 años de dictadura de buteflika
[Música]
mientras tanto marruecos ha fortalecido
su posición de hecho el reino alauita es
que más interés ha mostrado por reabrir
la frontera o hammett esto decía esto el
pasado mes de julio en su discurso del
día del trono
gracias
por su decisión
[Música]
sea como sea no parece que esta
situación vaya a cambiar en el corto
plazo atentos
[Música]
nuevas tensiones y antiguas disputas
hace prácticamente un año desde que el
frente polisario dio por concluido el
alto el fuego con marruecos que mantenía
la calma en el sáhara occidental' en
visual político ya os hablamos de ello y
tal y como muchos recordaréis la
situación se agravó cuando eeuu
reconoció la soberanía marroquí sobre la
antigua provincia española
la decisión del entonces presidente
trump fue una victoria para el reino
alauita todo un golpe para las
aspiraciones saharauis de celebrar algún
día un referéndum de independencia
a cambio marruecos tuvo que normalizar
sus relaciones diplomáticas con israel y
cuando hablamos de normalizar hablamos
de dar visibilidad porque la verdad es
que israel y marruecos siempre
mantuvieron unas relaciones muy
cordiales aunque no de forma oficial una
cordialidad sobre la que ya quedan pocas
dudas a la vista del amplio uso que las
autoridades marroquíes han hecho del
software espía israelí pegasus proyecto
pegasus argelia vigilada de cerca por
marruecos 6000 números de teléfono espía
van los servicios de inteligencia de
marruecos con el software pegasus
hablamos de casi todos los peces gordos
del país vecino el llamado le puso a la
élite política económica y militar que
ha dominado la república argelina desde
la independencia del país y tal y como
os podéis imaginar no hace falta ser
einstein la implicación de rabat en esta
trama de espionaje ha sentado fatal en
argel y para colmo el espionaje llega en
colaboración con israel porque amigos
argelia es un país donde todo va muy
lento y hoy por hoy sigue mostrándose
como uno de los defensores más
comprometidos con la causa palestina
así que argel está acusando a rabat de
traicionar al mundo musulmán al aliarse
con el enemigo judío
y claro los que de verdad están
encantados con todo este nuevo juego son
los israelíes porque siempre funciona la
lógica del enemigo de mi enemigo es mi
amigo en esa misma línea hace tres años
ga bat rompió relaciones con irán tras
salir a la luz que el frente polisario
estaba recibiendo el apoyo de irán y de
jezbolá así que digamos los bloques
parecen definidos marruecos e israel
versus argelia e irán por eso en agosto
el ministro de exteriores israelí visitó
a marruecos y no perdió la ocasión de
echar más leña al fuego lápiz el
ministro de exteriores israelí revela la
existencia de un acercamiento entre
argelia e irán pero ojo porque todos
estos renovados lazos entre marruecos
israel también le viene de perlas al
gobierno de argelia y es que veréis tal
y como os comentaba antes la caída de
los precios del petróleo y del gas han
sido terribles para la economía del país
especialmente porque con el dinero del
petróleo y el gas el gobierno
subvenciona va un montón de cosas y
claro en cuanto llegaron los recortes
las protestas ciudadanas se llevaron por
delante al régimen de buteflika pero
esperad un momento porque todo el
período post buteflika está siendo aún
peor
las luchas entre las diferentes
facciones del epu uag han aumentado el
caos en el país así que digamos que
dirigir las miradas contra un enemigo
exterior ya sea marruecos ya sea israel
es un argumento que la propaganda
argelina estaba deseosa de poder
explotar hasta qué punto bueno pues
directamente hasta el extremo de que
este verano el norte de argelia era
literalmente un infierno marruecos
ofreció dos aviones contraincendios y
cuál creéis que fue la respuesta
argelina pues antes quemarse que
humillarse mirad oídos sordos a la
oferta de ayuda de marruecos argelia de
unep y de ayuda europea amigos amigas el
try afloja es continuo ahora bien es
evidente que las economías de ambos
países ganarían mucho si ambos se
llevarán bien y desde luego las cosas en
argelia no van precisamente por el buen
camino especialmente si hablamos de
economía así que la pregunta es aquí
obedece tanto interés por enfrentarse
con rabat es tan sólo una cuestión de
propaganda y marketing político atentos
y
gas y furia
[Música]
argelia es el décimo productor mundial
de gas natural la mitad de este gas la
aprovecha para consumo propio y la otra
mitad la exporta y tal y como os podéis
imaginar sus principales clientes son
europeos un 60% del gas natural que
argelia vende al exterior llega a italia
oa españa en su gran mayoría a través de
gasoductos pero claro ya sabéis dónde
está situada argelia para que esos
gasoductos sean capaces de llegar al
continente europeo en su momento se tuvo
que negociar con los países vecinos
túnez para el gasoducto trasmediterránea
y marruecos para el gasoducto magreb
europa y si la actual crisis diplomática
entre los países ya ha tenido
consecuencias en una nueva escalada
argelia dejará de suministrar gas a
españa a través de marruecos si hay algo
que conecta a las economías de argelia y
marruecos
esa cosa es sin duda el gasoducto magreb
europa
1400 kilómetros de tubería desde los
yacimientos de argelia hasta córdoba de
los que 540 discurren por territorio
marroquí antes de cruzar el estrecho de
gibraltar fue inaugurado en el 96 y
actualmente tiene la capacidad de
transportar cada unos 10.000 millones de
metros cúbicos de gas natural las
negociaciones para la puesta en marcha
de este gasoducto arrancaron en 1990
justo en ese periodo de 5 años en los
que marruecos y argelia se llevaron
razonablemente bien y fue un acuerdo
pensado para que todas las partes
salieran ganando españa se aseguró su
principal fuente de suministro de gas al
tiempo que argelia se enriquecía
comercializando pero amigos la auténtica
clave de todo está en lo que sacó el
reino alauita
a cambio de los derechos de tránsito del
gas hacia la península ibérica'
marruecos percibe un peaje del 7 por
ciento del valor del gas exportado por
esta vía en 2019 esta cifra no llego a
los 50 millones de euros a causa de la
caída en el precio de los combustibles
pero en 2014 se acercó a los 200
millones además la empresa encargada de
operar el gasoducto es una compañía cuyo
accionariado comparten la española
natural y la portuguesa galp gracias a
un acuerdo de 1992 y cuya fecha de
extinción se fijó el 31 de octubre de
esto quiere decir que en cuestión de
días la propiedad del tramo marroquí del
gasoducto retornará al estado de
marruecos rabat ya haber dejado caer que
esperaban obtener ahora un acuerdo aún
más ventajoso el problema para marruecos
es que el magreb europa no es el único
gasoducto que transporta el gas argelino
hacia la península ibérica
en 2011 se inauguró el gasoducto
submarino medgaz que conecta
directamente los yacimientos argelinos
de gas con la red española en almería
tiene capacidad para 8 mil millones de
metros cúbicos esto significa que el gas
por sí solo sería insuficiente para
cubrir las necesidades de españa pero la
estatal argelina sonatrach ya ha movido
ficha
natural y sonatrach amplia en un 25% la
capacidad del gasoducto medgaz la
ampliación del medgaz llevará la
capacidad de exportación del gasoducto
hasta los 10 mil millones de metros
cúbicos según lo acordado se tiene que
completar antes del fin del 2021 aunque
por si acaso argelia le ha asegurado a
españa que en caso de retrasarse el
proyecto o necesitar más gas estaría en
disposición de suministrárselo mediante
barcos con gas natural licuado
y luego otro problema para marruecos es
que el gasoducto magreb europa de
proporciona ni más ni menos que el 45
por ciento de su demanda de gas a un
precio por debajo del del mercado un gas
natural que también abastece de
combustible a las plantas térmicas que
generan un 12 por ciento de la
electricidad del país es decir para
entendernos cortar el grifo del
gasoducto magreb europa supondría para
argelia quitarle a su vecino un
suministro energético relevante y una
notable fuente de ingresos
el mejor instrumento de propaganda
política aunque no el único lo cierto es
que últimamente en argel no pierden
ocasión para meterle el dedo en el ojo a
sus vecinos no sé si quizás tenga lo que
ver eso de que estimular un conflicto
suele ser la vía más empleada por
políticos de todo el mundo para esconder
sus fracasos y reforzar su liderazgo con
ciudadanos todos juntos contra el
enemigo
argelia cierra el espacio aéreo a todos
los aviones marroquíes sin embargo hay
dos asuntos que argelia no debería
ignorar
por un lado el gas natural licuado es
más caro que el gas que llega por
gasoducto por tanto el gas argelino
perderá competitividad y las
regasificadoras españolas pueden recibir
nl de argelia pero también de cualquier
otro lugar del mundo ojo con que se
retrase la ampliación luego por otro
lado sin el gasoducto magreb europa en
funcionamiento cualquier problema
técnico que impidiera a operar el
gasoducto directo con españa dejaría a
argelia sin alternativa para transportar
su gas natural hasta la península
ibérica' y con ello perdería una de sus
principales fuentes de ingresos
y también presente una cosa puede que
españa tenga almacenes de gas con los
que cubrir temporalmente cualquier falta
de suministro pero os aseguro que hoy
por hoy en las arcas argelinas no sobra
un dinar y eso sin contar el dinero que
perderían por dejar de suministrar a
marruecos
no
en fin el caso es que todo apunta a que
toda esta enorme tensión que se ha
disparado entre los dos vecinos puede
que sólo sea una argucia argelina para
reforzar su posición a la hora de
negociar el futuro del gasoducto magreb
europa y evitar que marruecos exija
revisar las condiciones que se pactaron
hace 30 años por tanto aunque mi sal
polític seguiremos atentos a esta
cuestión parece que por fortuna la
sangre no tiene pinta de llegar al río
en este caso a la frontera claro que ya
sabéis cómo son estas cosas la tensión
existe un error un malentendido pueden
hacer que de repente la pólvora comience
a arder jugar con fuego esto es amenazas
económicas y militares nunca suele ser
una buena idea pero te vas hasta aquí te
toca a ti turno para ti crees que al
final reinará la sensatez y se alcanzará
un acuerdo en el fondo viene bien tanto
a marruecos como argelia déjanos por
aquí abajo tus respuestas y ahora si
este vídeo te resultó interesante no
olvides darle al a un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]